how's it going as my spirit I said it
right yes I've been trying for weeks
actually I can do whatever I want so I
don't know if you have noticed but for
the past two weeks my videos hasn't been
showing up into sob boxes it's been a
YouTube glitch it hasn't been for
everyone but I think it's fixed I don't
know I've been getting a lot of people
saying likewise near your video showing
up behind you making videos and I'm like
[ __ ] that's not why I'm making this
video I recently got the opportunity to
go to the catacombs of Paris along with
universals as above so below and I've
been in the catacombs of Sweden and they
were pretty nice I'm not gonna lie I
didn't know what the catacombs in Paris
look like but then I go go
you
[Music]
so basically what's gonna happen is me
and Mars are gonna travel to Paris she's
gonna film some behind-the-scenes stuff
and I'm gonna walk all by myself through
the catacombs of Paris as a challenge
and they will set up scares for me so it
will be like a real-life horror game
which is pretty awesome I never done
anything like this before but honestly I
don't know if I can handle it but yeah
if I make it out alive it should be
pretty cool
there's mourning from this coming and
but you bros will be able to participate
as well you bros will pretty much decide
what's gonna scare me and how and stuff
like that so that's pretty cool to get a
better idea of how scary it will be I'll
leave a link in the description for the
trailer or you can watch it on the in
slates last but not least I wanted to
announce the charity livestream that
we're doing this Sunday at the 27th of
April at London time 7:00 p.m. all the
info that you need is in description
twitch.tv slash PewDiePie it's all for
charity it's all for the bros Save the
Children campaign thank you both so much
before this is poured on the Humble
Bundle it went really well so thank you
same thing with the charity so far
there's only one week left to donate so
please if you haven't done it already
please do it right now like in the
description love you Russ so much I will
stroke my buttcheeks I'm pretending that
they are it's very similar but anyway
that's all for me Thank You boys for
watching it comes to brofist lovely
breasts why am I not a professional
singer [ __ ]